вже другові виборювати вибори на весь до
вам в арсеналі за образом балаклії на
харківщині завив також його каю вали
пошуку 20 тисяч людей
трагедія забрала тіло днів і esinco
ще двоє за знав і час нам по переднього
причиною ви бухим називають до версії
інцидент балаклії далеко на перший в
історії на закладеної україни ченина
гарчиш а. нам а пиво 100 них руки але в
абадане весь кава склади показати у
вас ілана за париже лаурив і в тричі ж і
у 2003 у займалася вона військових
складах у бахнути і кілочки артемівськ 5
руки в тому масштабно пізніше раз
спалахнуло носкова щі боєприпасів а весь
кови чистий її клич на харківщині
ви бух це справа новий 2 також нею 1 за
100 них трагедій пізніше новачкових складів
у свата вам ще на луганщині у дів на
2015 забрала жити а4 людей чому ви бах і
на військових складах стало фактичною
норму в Україні
експерти називають кілька причин
диверсій вид диверсії до простий
виробництв удар насті
до простого нахабство боєприпасу бачу
що пороху та боєприпаси вмістити порах
того буху віри що ви не
столітті у Вільнюсі про процес утилізації
вони могли випадати раб цієї і на чорний
ринок
а сліди треба приходять і сліди всім
необхідним приховувати випущено вікових
складах вид бувати у регулярно con
статуї ризиковий експерт ігор козячий
абизов об'єкти таким інцидентом ладу
email хвалить і стратегічні рішення та
гаранту вати б спк складе але слухаючи вин
харчування поля війни в тому, що вони
ну ви бухнули до видихнув і харчування
тому так ви батьки і рекламу ви
бухав і
і 2 роки тому видихала і такі самі
заяву було поцілунках втрати
жужка в як би дрон розуміти але всі ціни
серйозно відсік кожен те, що сама
система політично та адміністративного на
низ дат на
поставить і наприклад завдань я за
безпечні без пеку арсеналі вид по видно
так стандарті на те і довести факти
сидону до логічного завершення україна
фактична стала складом боєприпасів
після розпаду ссср на її території
результаті перевезли лівої ділянки арсеналі
iv столітті розміщувалася а українок
варшавського договору скільки сама запасі
в боєприпаси на території України
рахова ти в край складно ще дві тисячі
п'ятому уроці експерта центру розумкова
називали цифру у маже два з половиною
мільйона тонн